doctors in California are trying to
solve a family stunning medical mystery
two young siblings four and six years
old were diagnosed with the same kind of
brain tumor within two weeks of each
other now their parents are speaking out
in the hopes of raising awareness and
encouraging new research Jamie yuccas
shows us the families brave fight I
think it's pretty rare to have two kids
who just are best friends
Kalea and Noah Avery have been bonded
from the beginning but their parents
never imagined the siblings would battle
cancer together it was right around
Memorial Day when six-year-old Kalia
started to experience severe headaches
and vomiting after repeated trips to the
emergency room an MRI revealed a tumor
when you heard a mass at the back of her
brain what went through your mind I
literally I mean I just I broke down
like fear the immediate reaction is fear
it's too hard to even say the words out
loud when you first get that diagnosis
you know in 14 days you have a girl who
loves a skateboard and play soccer and
hang out with their friends - she's got
that brain surgery and has brain cancer
like your whole world just stops less
than a week after Kalia had surgery to
remove her tumor her brother started
complaining about headaches when he said
you know my head hurts between my eye as
he's pointing right to where her sister
was we're like okay he's mimicking his
sister he misses his sister it's just
him dealing with all these emotions but
an MRI would reveal the same aggressive
tumor in the back of the brain known as
medulloblastoma the cancer affects
between 250 and 500 children in the US
every year I literally like I didn't
even respond I kind of went numb we're
all sitting hit with this and it's like
we're starting all over again with our
second child at that point I was a guy
how are we gonna get through this dr.
Allen Wayne at Children's Hospital Los
Angeles is treating the Avery children
they both had surgery already they're
doing well postoperatively
next comes beginning the chemotherapy
and in some cases additional therapy
Bianchi he and his team are also looking
for the cause of the cancer by studying
potential gene abnormalities it's
extremely rare to have two cancers in a
family which in and of itself raises the
possibility of this being an inherited
genetic predisposition what is the
likelihood that the cancer could come
back for these kids most of the time
with medulloblastoma the children are
cured but because the tumor affects the
cerebellum balance and coordination can
be affected the siblings are now working
with a team of oncologists and physical
therapists facing the road to recovery
together with the situation we're in
there's just you know different
victories there are different goals that
we have as a family and you know we look
forward to hitting those milestones when
they're like how you know how is Noah
doing her house Clea doing and you know
I'll say I she laughed for the first
time it's like I brings tears to my eyes
like just joy like the simplest things
are amazing now for CBS this morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles Jamie yuccas
thank you